this is iOS and it would be our kicks
and this is unbox my first impression of
the shoe is on hold it stands out brings
a different kind of look to it and this
colorway is black and white I really
like it
blacks my favorite color and I think the
red is a really nice touch I have played
in the thirty-fourth they're very
comfortable and for me somebody my size
and my agility they work perfectly for
me another thing I like about the shoe
is how it's like being inside is black
or the outside it's more white I think
that really stands out like you put them
together it gives like a different look
to the shoe which i think is dope and
then I like low mid cut shoes like and
for a low mid cut shoe this is very
comfortable and it holds its own my
first reaction to it was kind of like
wow cuz I didn't know what to expect
you never know what to expect when you
knew she was coming out so when I first
saw it I was a wild like it's dope
I like how has like the Jordan logo
obviously but I also had Nike gear on
the back I think that was a nice touch
when it came to choosing a brand for me
it was kind of all about family it's
kind of how I grew up and I just felt
like Jordan Jordan brand was home like
for the most comfortable there and I
feel like I can do big things with them
when I first got the first shipment and
there's a lot of sneakers I'm not gonna
like pick every day like I go into my
closet and I'm like I don't know which
one to wear today so I try to make some
match up as much as I can my first
experience with Jordan Brand at the
Harlan Park was it was dope there were a
lot of kids out there they were hyped
they showed a lot of love when I walked
up to the court so I mean I had to do
something special for him
a windmill and in between the legs and
the different colorway of the sneaker
but I mean it was all love it's a
different feeling like it can't be
described like when little kid comes up
to you and says he wears a certain shoe
because of you like just oh my god
that's the only word I can think of at
the moment would just you know your door
something right this is I Winston this
is the Air Jordan 34 and you would be
our kicks
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]